The daily sweep is by far the easiest
way to become profitable fast. And it
works so well that it almost feels like
cheating. If someone had told me this 14
years ago when I started trading, I
would have been able to start getting
results like this, this, and this much
sooner. Today, you'll learn how this
simple approach to trading will help you
avoid the fatal mistakes that plague
most traders. That way, you can cut out
the wasted time and effort and become
consistently profitable much sooner.
Let's hop right into the first step you
need to take. All right, let's get into
the daily sweep trading model. But
first, let's talk about the trader
dilemma. Now, for years, I'd open up my
charts each morning completely lost, not
knowing where to focus. I'd have six
time frames open, checking the daily, 4
hour, 1 hour, 15 minute, 5 minute, 1
minute, paralysis by analysis, and I'd
miss moves because I was looking
everywhere and nowhere at the same time.
Now, I bet that sounds familiar, right?
See, the problem isn't that you don't
know how to analyze a chart. It's that
you don't trust your system enough to
help you anticipate what's going to
happen next. The uncertainty brings
anxiety and before you know it, you're
trading based off of emotions instead of
data. Now, that was until I combined
three very simple steps to develop a
plan before the session even starts. So,
when I'm sitting at the charts, I know
exactly what to look for. And if it
doesn't do what I expect, then I don't
take a trade. So, the first concept,
let's talk about swing points. Now, what
is a swing point? Simply put, a swing
low is a candle where both the candle
before it and after it have higher lows.
And a swing high is a candle where both
the candle before it and after it have
lower highs. So we have a three candle
pattern as you guys can see here on the
right. This bullish swing point. We have
a low then we have a lower low and a
higher low. So for the fact that we have
two higher lows on either side of this
one candle. This low here becomes our
bullish swing point. And opposingly for
a bearish swing point we have this high,
a higher high and then a lower high. So,
in this three candle formation, we have
a lower high on either side of candle
number two. Now, this high becomes our
bearish swing point. Now, you're
probably asking, why do these swing
points actually matter? Well, first of
all, you're not just drawing random
support and resistance. You're not
trying to just find key levels based on
how the chart feels. You are objectively
marking swing points that have already
happened. And this is where most traders
trip themselves up is that they try and
anticipate way too much and they lose
sight of the data that's actually being
presented in front of them. So again,
you're objectively marking swing points
that have already happened and already
printed points where price reversed
before, which gives us the overall
direction of a market. So if we
consistently see bullish swing points
being printed in the market, we can
anticipate that the market's going to
continue higher. Now, when I started
doing this every single evening as part
of my routine, I just stopped feeling
lost every single day. I knew exactly
which direction I wanted to trade the
following day. No more guessing, no more
staring at charts hoping for
inspiration. Now, this one simple
foundational piece will remove a lot of
the confusion that you have when you sit
down in front of your charts. So, for
me, at the end of every daily closure at
around 5 or 6 p.m., I'll go in and
analyze the chart and just mark out the
swing points. So, as you guys can see
here, I've marked out all of the bullish
swing points in this uptrend. Obviously,
the market does not go just in a
straight line. So, at some points, we do
retest these swing lows, but if we print
a new swing low, then we can anticipate
that the market is going to continue
higher in that same direction. So, now
you've got your road map, right? You
know where price wants to go, but
trading these levels blindly is
financial suicide. Now, trust me, I've
got the blown accounts to prove it. And
there's a specific pattern that forms at
these swing points that changed
everything for me. Now, it's so reliable
that once I learned to spot it, my win
rate jumped from 35% to over 50%
literally overnight. And the crazy part
is is that you can see these patterns
form in real time. And it's not in
hindsight. It's not subjective. It's
clear as day once you know what to look
for. Now, here's that pattern. All
right. Simple. So, you've got your road
map. You know where price wants to go.
But trading these levels blindly is
financial suicide. Trust me, I've got
the blown accounts to prove it. Now,
there's a specific pattern that forms at
these swing points that changed
everything for me. And it's so reliable
that once I learned to spot it, my win
rate jumped from 35% to over 50%
literally overnight. And the crazy part
is is that you can see these patterns
form in real time. It's not in
hindsight. It's not subjective. And it's
clear as day once you know what to look
for. Now, here's the pattern. It is a
swing failure pattern. Now, what is a
swing failure? It's when price briefly
breaks a significant swing high or low,
but quickly reverses and fails to
sustain the move and closes back within
the previous range, [music] indicating a
potential trend reversal or liquidity
grab. So, as you guys can see here, we
have this previous swing low and we've
raided that level. So, we've briefly
taken it out, but we get no
follow-through. The following candle
closes back above the swing point. Now,
when we have this, this is our confirmed
bullish swing failure pattern. Now,
again, we are waiting for this candle
here to close. If this candle here is
just moving around and it hasn't closed
yet, then it hasn't confirmed that we
have a swing failure pattern. And as a
bearish example, we've briefly taken out
the high, we have failure to follow
through, and then we get the closure
back into the range. Okay, now you're
probably asking, great, we have a swing
failure pattern confirmation, but how
exactly do we trade it? So, in this
example, let's say we're bullish. We
have this previous swing low. What we're
looking for is a swing failure pattern.
Then we get this brief run on price, and
then we get a closure back above that
old low. So on the close of this candle,
what we're anticipating is the next
candle or the next couple candles to
give us some type of entry opportunity
to position ourselves long because we've
already confirmed that the market is
bullish based on this swing failure
pattern. Now, even after I understood
where to look and what to wait for, I
was still getting stopped out constantly
because my entries were just terrible.
I'd see the swing failure pattern happen
and just market order in. There was no
precision and no plan. My stop losses
were either too wide, so I was losing
too much per trade, or they were too
tight, meaning I was getting stopped out
right before the actual move happened.
And I needed a way to time my entry
perfectly. And that's where this process
saved my career. Instead of flipping
constantly between time frames without
confirmation, I was only utilizing the
low time frames once the market allowed
me to. And if we didn't get a closure
back into the range, then there was
absolutely no reason to even look at a
5-minute chart because there's no entry.
But once we have a confirmed swing
failure pattern, we then drop down to a
5-minute time frame. And this is where
we start hunting for an entry model.
Okay, that's great. But what are my
entry models? So, I focus on three main
entry models. Fair value gaps, inverted
fair value gaps, and order [music]
blocks. Now, let's say you don't want to
trade ICT or you think ICT doesn't work.
Feel free to use various methods such as
VWAP, moving averages, volume profiles,
whatever resonates with you. Because why
do they all work? It's because the
context and narrative of the market is
already in place with steps one and two.
Okay, we have a swing low in the market
that's telling us the market's bullish
and then we get a swing failure pattern.
So, what that essentially tells us is
the market is still bullish, but they're
trying to manipulate people into going
short. Now, if there's no follow-through
for the bears, then obviously the market
is just going to continue higher. And at
that point, when you get the context and
the narrative correct, you can really
use any type of entry model because
honestly, all of the heavy work and
analysis is already out of the way. So
again, these are the entry models that I
use. I'll use a fair value gap, which is
a three candle pattern that leaves a gap
between the high of candle 1 and the low
of candle 2. So what I look for is a
retracement into this area. I'll enter
long, you know, put my stop loss around
here or maybe at the lows and target a
1:2 or 1 to three. And an inverted fair
value gap is essentially a fair value
gap that gets broken to the upside and
then we wait for the retracement. Now
what's the risk management behind this?
So stop loss obviously is a logical area
based on the entry method. So obviously
a logical area based on the entry
method. You know if you're using VWOP
maybe you want to put your stop loss
below the VWOP. Or if you're just using
a candlestick pattern like an engulfing
candle or pin bar you want to put your
stop loss below the low of that candle
if you're attempting a long. Now, what
we're looking for is a fixed 1:2 or 1:3
risk-toreward. Now, you're going to take
one or two attempts per day. If trade
one is a loser, trade number two, use
half of the risk. That way, your max
daily loss is only negative - 1 and a
half R. Now, if you go through your
charts, you're going to find many, many,
many examples of this exact model
playing out perfectly. So, let's get
into the actual trade examples. All
right, example one. So, you guys can see
here that this market is overall
bearish. You guys can see here on this
Tuesday, market traded lower, closed
lower. This Wednesday the market traded
lower. So overall on the higher time
frame we are bearish. So what we're
going to do when uh we sit down to
analyze our charts in the evening is
we're going to mark out previous swing
highs. Okay, very important swing highs.
And what we're going to wait for is a
swing failure pattern. Okay, what we're
looking for is a raid on one of these
highs and then the market turning over
and then providing us a swing failure
pattern. So again, I'm looking at the
NASDAQ market. So we're trying to trade
within these trading windows. I would
not anticipate trading during London
session if I'm going to trade NASDAQ.
So, let's fast forward through this
market and see what we get as we go
forward. So, you guys can see here, this
is London session, right? So, 3:00 a.m.
4:00 a.m. we are getting this run above
this swing high here as well as this
swing high. But, if we do see a swing
failure pattern within this window,
we're going to avoid that. Let's keep
fast forwarding. Now, we are approaching
equity open. Right now, it's 7:00 a.m.
in the morning. So, I would not look at
this as a swing failure pattern because
we are approaching equity open. And with
equity open, something can happen. We
might get volatility. Okay, here we go.
So, we have this swing high being rated
and then we get this very strong
rejection on equity open. So, what we're
going to do here now is drop down into
our 5minute time frame. All right. So,
I'm going to label this as our swing
failure pattern. This is really the
volatility that we're looking for inside
of the time that we're looking for it.
And we're not trading this one because
it's 7:00 a.m. If you try and trade
these setups off hours, your data is
going to be very poor. And trust me,
I've been through it. So, we have our
swing failure pattern, right? We have
this swing high. Let me just remove all
this information because it becomes
unnecessary. This is the swing high that
we're looking at, right? This is our
right on the high. You guys can see that
there's zero followthrough and we get a
closure back in the range. Again, we
have to wait for the closure. We don't
know if this candle at the equity open
at 10:00 a.m. We don't know if it's
going to fail and trade lower and trade
back into the range. So, we have to wait
for this. This is our confirmation. Now,
what we're going to do is now drop into
a 5minut time frame and look for an
entry model. So, I can see here that we
have this fair value app here. And what
I'm looking for is an entry model on
this lower time frame. So you guys can
see here that up here is our swing
failure. Now I'm looking for an entry
model. Okay, this is where what the only
time I'm going to drop down into a lower
time frame is after I've done steps one
and two. Step one is finding that
overall direction using swing points.
Step two is waiting for that swing
failure pattern. Now step three, [music]
again, you're only going to the low time
frame when you have the previous two
already. Now let's fast forward and see
if we could find an entry. Okay, we got
a nice closure here. closing through 50%
of that candle of this fair value gap.
Okay. So, let's say we take an entry
here. And let's just say that we missed
the entry all the way up here. We were
waiting for a closure through that fair
value gap. So, what I'm going to do is
actually put my stop loss above this
candle. And let's just say we don't get
the best entry here. And let's just say
we're going to target 2R. All right. So,
now we have all three steps in place. We
have the swing high. We have the swing
failure pattern. A failure to close
above that high. And then we get our
entry model. Right? You know, ideally,
we break the fair value gap and it
doesn't run this hard. But let's just
say we're late to the party, which is
totally fine. Now, let's keep fast
forwarding and see if this trade
actually pans out. All right, now let's
keep fast forwarding and actually see if
this trade pans out. Already, we got a
bit of retracement. We have more fair
value gaps here. We're tested that fair
value gap and there you go. Target hit.
All right, so there was trade one,
right? We identified all these swing
highs. We were waiting for a swing
failure pattern around equity open and
we got it. Now, let's keep fast
forwarding. Let's say after this day,
you really weren't certain where the
market was going. So, we didn't
anticipate having any type of direction.
Uh, we didn't mark out any swing highs
or lows and we kind of just chalk this
day up as a no trade day. But, let's say
we sit down in the afternoon and we
anticipate that, hey, this market did
retrace quite a bit and we did invert
this fair value gap here. So, let's say
the following day on the 6th that we're
anticipating bullishness. Okay, so we're
going to come in and mark out our swing
lows because we're bullish and we're
looking for these swing lows to give us
a swing failure pattern for the
following day. Now, let's just fast
forward and see what we get. Now, here
we get our swing failure pattern, okay?
Cuz we're bullish. We've determined that
we're bullish based on this price
action. So, we're looking for a swing
low to be broken and fail, right? So, we
have zero follow-through. We get a
closure back above the swing low. But
let's just say that it's not quite time
to trade yet. So, we have to wait for
equity open. So, let's just fast forward
a bit here, and we're going to fast
forward to equity open, which is 9:30 in
the morning. So, let's say we have this
swing failure pattern, but it's not
quite close enough to equity open. What
we're going to do is, you know,
anticipate some movement maybe leading
up to the open and maybe this is an
opportunity where we can get long ahead
of the open. So, let's fast forward a
bit and see if we get any closer towards
the equity open. Okay, here's 7 a.m.
right here is giving us indication that
maybe this is going to turn into a
bullish fair value gap. So, I'm going to
just mark that out and let's say I sit
down in my charts. This is our 8 a.m.
close. Okay, so 8 a.m. leading up into
9:00 a.m. Now, I'm very attentive
because this might provide an
opportunity where we've already gotten
our swing failure pattern. This market
is already showing displacement away
from that low. And maybe I just need to
position myself before the open. So,
this candle closed at 8:00 a.m. Let's
just say we want to wait till 9:00 a.m.
Okay, 9:00 a.m. We're getting a
retracement here. And let's just say
that I want to hop in and look for an
entry model on the lower time frame. So,
nothing quite yet. I'm going to mark out
this level in case we get an inverted
fair value gap. You know, 905. Okay,
here we might get a change in stage of
delivery because we have this closure
above this 5minute candle. Mark this
blue. So, we have a possible order block
being formed. Oh, 920 hit it very close.
Let's just say we're going to go long
here because we are attempting a long
based on this order block, right? We get
a closure above this down candle. And
this is my entry model. Let's just
anticipate that this is my entry [music]
model. I'm waiting for a closure above a
down close candle. This is our
retracement into that order block. And
let's just say I'm going to put my stop
loss, I don't know, below the low of
this swing point. Okay? Cuz on a lower
time frame, this is our swing point. So
on a higher time frame, we already have
confirmation what we're looking for. We
wanted that swing low to be braided and
then we got a swing failure pattern. And
now this is really just our entry. So
let's just say we're going to aim for a
3:1, right? Cuz that kind of brings us
above London high here. So let's see
what equity open gives us. Okay, a lot
of volatility. This actually did retrace
down into this fair value gap here,
guys. So, let's say you missed the entry
off the open. This is right around 940.
So, right around 940, you get another
opportunity to get long inside of this
fair value gap. Okay? So, let's say if
you wanted to use this fair value gap,
your stop loss ideally should go below
of candle number one. All right? So,
this is candle number one. Your stop
should go below. And I would say give
yourself a little bit more room cuz you
guys can see that it came very, very
close to that. But based on where my
entry was, based off this order block,
we're fine, right? Let's fast forward.
And there's our target. So that's a 3
to1 trade. And with all the criteria
that we're talking about as far as this
model goes. So as you guys can see here,
I actually took this trade. I had this
swing low marked out. We got the swing
failure pattern. We were trading up in
the inverted fair value gap. I did end
up going long. I did get stopped out. I
did re-enter and then I exited at this
previous swing high back here. So I'm
going to actually walk you guys through
one more trade example that I took
today. Now today is Monday. So Sunday
night I sat down and looked at where the
daily candle closed on Friday. Now, this
daily candle right closed above the
previous day's [music] candle. So, what
I'm looking for is bullishness in this
market, and I want to see these highs be
ran out up here. So, I have these old
highs back here that I'm looking to see
the market trade to. So, what I'm going
to do is drop down to the hourly time
frame. And then what I'm going to do
from here is plot out my swing low
points. Okay? So, let me just remove
those higher time frame levels. I'm
going to plot out my swing low points
from the previous day. And this is just
done on the hourly time frame because
I'm using a 5m minute for entry. All
right. We have our swing low points
blotted out. There's not too many
between this one and this one. Okay, so
what we're looking for is a swing point
in between here. Maybe it's this one,
but we're looking for that swing failure
pattern. So, let's keep fast forwarding
through this. All right, we've got a
swing failure pattern here, but it's at
6 p.m. Not going to take it. Right,
that's the Asian session. We're not
going to take that one. Right, we get a
run, a very, very steep run lower
overnight. We're waiting for equity
open. Okay, here we have a swing point.
This is our swing low. Right, we have a
swing low. We have this being rated, but
it's still 1000 p.m. at night. All
right, we have another swing low here.
Again, I'm waiting for the right times
to trade. I'm not trading during Asia,
right? I'm not trading during London.
I'm waiting for the right time to trade.
All right, this is 1:00 a.m. 2 a.m.
Let's lead up to equity open, right? We
have another swing here. So, yes, you
can look at this as a swing failure, but
the context of it is not something that
I would take because we're off trading
hours. I can't emphasize this enough.
Okay, this is part of this system that
you have to be very diligent with. You
can't just take these concepts and, you
know, run free with it. There is a
structured process to doing this. We're
waiting for equity open because that's
when NASDAQ is the most active. All
right, we have a swing failure pattern
here. So, we get a run on this low and
then we get a nice closure here. Let's
see what happens leading up to equity
open, though. All right, this is 7 a.m.
So, at 7 a.m., we have an inverted fair
value gap. Okay, now we're approaching
the time where I'm hunting trades. I'm
not hunting trades back here because the
hours just don't make sense. Okay, time
is more important than price. Okay, we
get a nice run here. Get a closure at
8:00 a.m. And let's just say I wanted to
get long somewhere around here, right?
We have this fair value gap. Let's say I
missed that one. I want to go long. I'm
going to put my long position, you know,
let's say we get it up here leading up
to 8 a.m. I'm going to put my stop loss
here and aim for a 3R. All right, 8 a.m.
close enough for me to be honest to take
a trade pre-market. Okay, that's a
little sketchy, right? Is that not
sketchy? I use this swing low as our
stop loss. That is a very deep deep
retracement. You have to be able to
sustain that. But I know that I'm on
side because everything else that the
market is giving us on a higher time
frame makes sense. Okay, we have our
swing failure pattern. We have higher
time frame inverted fair value gap and
we have our entry model on the lower
time frame. Let's say I didn't enter at
the right time. That's totally okay. We
have this bullish fair value gap but our
stop loss below the low. Now we are
going to see where the market takes us
ahead of the equity open. All right,
let's say we got stopped out there and
maybe we just entered at the wrong time.
We entered at 7:55 and we got stopped
out. But now this is 9:25. Okay, 925.
Maybe we're trying to hunt that again.
Okay, we retested this fair value gap
again. We've respected it. Not only
that, but we have a swing failure on a
lower time frame. We have this old swing
low and then we get a closure back above
here. So, let's say we take a 1 hour
loss and then we go long again, right,
ahead of the open. Maybe we give
ourselves a little bit more wiggle room
and we put our stop loss at the low of
this favor gap down here and then we
target the same 3R. Maybe we use the
same target. Okay, so leading up to the
equity open, we still have the same
idea. Maybe we just entered a little bit
too early. That's totally fine.
Everything else on the higher time frame
is still telling us, hey, this is a
swing failure pattern. We're just trying
to find an entry model. We try we're
trying to pinpoint precision. Okay, so
maybe we take a half risk on this next
trade. Let's see what happens at the
open. Boom. 3R [music] bagged. So,
ideally, this trade made up for the loss
that we just took. Now, I actually want
to point out that I did not get stopped
out this morning. I actually entered
this trade about 7:19 a.m. I gave the
call on my Discord channel, and we
entered based off of this 5minute fair
value gap. So based on this 5minute fair
value gap, my stop loss was much much
lower. Now I'm going to share those
Discord messages here just so you guys
can see that I'm not lying. I actually
posted this in my Discord and it's
timestamped. So at 7:19 a.m. long here,
everyone. And then at 7:54, I mentioned
in the next week or two, I'm going to
revisit the JCAP trading model and redo
the content around it. Here's a proven
model that works very well in most
conditions. Step one, determine daily
bias based on D1 time frame. Plot all
swing points from the previous day at
session start. So London or New York.
Wait for a swing failure pattern. You
have a lower time frame execution
starting the following hour. So fair
value gap, inverted fair value gap,
order block, change in state of
delivery. And we're going to target
fixed one or two R. Okay, so if bullish,
we are waiting for a swing low raid or
failure pattern. And that means no raid,
no trade. And here at 857, I adjusted my
stop and I put my stop below the hourly
low, fully out for plus 2 R. Now, I knew
I needed a simple process, something I
could execute the same way every single
day, whether I was at my desk or
checking my phone between meetings. But
every strategy I learned had 15 steps,
required perfect conditions, and it fell
apart the moment the market got choppy.
So, when I stripped trading down to just
these three steps, everything finally
clicked. Step one gives you focus and
direction. There's no more analysis
paralysis. You have swing lows and swing
highs being put in the market. That
should give you the overall direction.
Step two gives you confirmation. There's
no more chasing and no more guessing or
waiting for swing failure patterns. And
step three, the trade execution gives
you precision. There's no more bad
entries or wide stops. Now, I encourage
you all to back test this model and
trade in the live markets because
obviously nothing beats experience.
Recently, I open the doors to my inner
circle program where I directly mentor
traders, teaching them this exact
strategy and trading it alongside with
them every single week and achieve
payouts like this, this, and this. I'll
leave a link down in the description. If
it still works, then spots are open. But
if it doesn't, then that means spots are
closed for the next enrollment. As
always, I hope you guys enjoyed the
video. Don't forget to like and
subscribe and I'll see you in the next